ya llevamos varias horas de
manifestación por el momento todo en
calma Es cierto que hay algunos tramos
en esta larga marcha que va desde la
Plaza de la República a la Plaza de la
nación en que hay una cierta atención
sobre todo cuando se llega a la cabecera
de este movimiento donde está lleno de
policías recordemos que hay un
despliegue especial hoy de 13.000
hombres policías y gendarmes en toda
Francia la mitad de ellos casi en París
pues la última manifestación que fue muy
masiva también fue muy violenta con
mucha quema de basura y de basureros por
lo tanto la policía hoy ha previsto un
dispositivo fuera de lo común sin
embargo por ahora todo está muy
tranquilo recordemos que además la
policía y el gobierno de Manuel macron
están siendo escrutados por el consejo
europeo de los Derechos Humanos la liga
francesa de los derechos humanos y
también muchos políticos que aseguran
que las fuerzas policiales francesas
ejercen una violencia innecesaria en
contra de los manifestantes en los
últimos días